The third algorithm we'll cover today is called a histogram. Now, what's a histogram?
It's a means of categorizing and usually displaying data that varies with a particular measurement.
In practice, to create a histogram, we take a measurement for each item in a population
and then place those measurements into a set of bins that we define,
where each bin covers a certain range of measurements.
This is much easier to explain with an example.
I'm recording this lecture at Udacity headquarters in Palo Alto, California.
So let's say I walk out on the street in Palo Alto,
and record the height of each of the next 100 adults that happen to walk by.
What that gets me is a list of 100 measurements.
Here's what that list might look like.
But it's difficult to draw out conclusions from such a list.
Instead, what I'll do is create a histogram.
I'm going to specify a number of bins, for instance, 4 bins, shorter than 150 centimeters,
between 150 and 165 centimeters, between 165 and 180 centimeters,
and taller than 180 centimeters.
Then I'll place each measurement into its bin.
So every time someone walks by, I place another tick mark into the bin.
Here, for instance, we might end up with the measurements 12, 34, 38, 60 out of 100 people.
Often in statistics you might want to plot this histogram, which might
give you a curve that tells you something interesting about the data.
Let me introduce you to one specific operation you might want to do on a histogram of data
because you'll be doing this in your assignment.
For the histogram we just showed here, we might want to compute the answer to the question
"if I'm this tall, how many people are shorter than me?" for all bins in the histogram.
This computation is called the cumulative distribution function on a histogram.
It's also known as a definite integral.
We want to compute the cumulative distribution function on this histogram.
The input of the histogram is an array of values, for instance, 12, 34, 38, 16.
In 1 word, or 2 words, to be a little more precise,
what is the operation we need to do to this input
to get the cumulative distribution function?